hasta donde nos quedamos en el vídeo
pasado y yo hablamos de un misterio
alrededor de la ley de benford y les
preguntamos qué ocurre con la ley de
belford esta idea de que si tomamos
países al azar y tomamos sus poblaciones
y de sus poblaciones tomamos el dígito
más significativo y luego lo gráfica mos
vamos a encontrar que el número de
países que su dígito más significativo
es uno contra los que su dígito más
significativo es dos o los que es tres o
los que es cuatro ocurre con mayor
frecuencia los que tienen el 1 esto es
como una constante universal y me
gustaría que tuviéramos más gráficas las
gráficas son divertidas podrían buscar
información sobre el mercado de valores
y ver qué ocurre y todos siguen esta
curva y eso es lo que los hace realmente
misterioso y es lo que hablábamos en el
vídeo anterior
y como lo platicábamos en el vídeo si
observamos fenómenos acumulativos por
ejemplo los números de fibonacci o las
potencias de 2 se ajustan perfectamente
a la ley de benford en estos casos
infinitos es muy difícil graficar y de
estos pues más o menos qué es esto como
el 70 por ciento son los que tienen
pagos como su dígito más significativo
sí sí y si lo quieres probar pues
tomemos el primer millón de las
potencias de dos y después tomar sus
porcentajes y nos daría una muy buena
aproximación de esto claro y si te
detienes a meditar en esto observarás
que esto es algo más profundo para mí
esto no es tan misterioso bueno por una
parte esto cuadra perfectamente con las
matemáticas pero por otro lado tienes
que tener un muy buen entendimiento tal
vez es buena idea en este momento de
tener el vídeo y pensarlo meditarlo
porque esto es algo profundo
nosotros ya lo hicimos y una pista muy
útil para nosotros fue la escala
logarítmica
y justamente aquí tenemos una escala
logarítmica lo que nos dice la escala es
que para distancias iguales representan
potencias de 10 en una escala lineal
aquí tendríamos el 1 tal vez aquí
vendría el 2 o el 3 o más bien entonces
este es el 1 luego excedió un 10 luego
un 20 luego un 30 pero en una escala
logarítmica las distancias iguales son
potencias de 10 tantas veces 10 1 a 10
10 a 100 100 a 1000 y observa cómo
quedan los números en la escala o sea la
distancia que hay entre el 1 y 2 es
mayor que la que hay entre el 2 y el 3 y
cada vez se va haciendo más pequeña y
cada vez más pequeña hasta llegar al 10
y esto es una gran pista para entender
la ley de benford y esto nos muestra y
es una gran pista que si tomo esta área
que está aquí esta área que estoy
coloreando y la comparo con esta que
está acá el porcentaje será exactamente
igual a esta área que está acá es
exactamente el porcentaje que está aquí
y si tomo esta área que está acá como un
porcentaje de la anterior que más o
menos es como el 70 por ciento y es este
porcentaje éste que más o menos parece
que hay alguna congruencia hay una
conexión una gran pista y para cualquier
potencia claro y un gran consejo es es
graficar las potencias de dos en una
escala logarítmica y vamos a intentarlo
así es al menos para las potencias de
dos o para la secuencia de fibonacci y
dos a la primera es 22 a la segunda
potencia es 4 y luego obtendremos un 8 y
luego el 16 estará más o menos por aquí
y luego nos vamos al 32 y luego iremos
al 64 el 64 está la potencia
definitivamente tiene sentido 40 50
estará más o menos por aquí y lo que
observamos es que cuando gráfica moss
las potencias de dos en una escala
logarítmica están a distancias iguales
para ver cómo está distancias se
mantienen si lo graficar amos en una
escala
entonces irían creciendo el doble cada
vez y lo que está ocurriendo es que
tenemos algo que va recorriendo de una
manera uniforme como si fuera caminando
imaginemos que vamos caminando y si la
banqueta sobre la que vamos caminando
fuera de escala logarítmica entonces
habría más pases si si contáramos los
pasos que hay en el bloque entre el 1 y
el 2 y pasaría lo mismo entre el bloque
del 10 al 20 y habría más pasos que
entre el 9 y el 10 si efectivamente eso
pasaría si tomamos los bloques donde
empiezan con 1 como el del 1 al 2 el del
10 al 20 es del 100 a tomar pasos del
mismo tamaño nos va a dar esta
distribución a menos que los pasos sean
casos especiales para las personas que
caminan logarítmica mente
eso es exactamente lo que su reciclado
en esos casos especiales en las que la
longitud de tu paso sea de 10 claro y
todas las variaciones ligeras de esto te
van a proporcionar la distribución la
distribución de venta
la distribución deben y aún cuando creo
que ahora ya lo entendemos esto es
fascinante esto explica esta serie de
números pero ahora tendremos que
encontrar una forma de como conectarlo
con esto y la idea general era para
población con información del mundo real
sí pero la idea de benford parece
funcionar para cosas que crecen
exponencialmente así es con tenencias de
gracias de dos si como las potencias de
dos y las poblaciones crecen
exponencialmente y en finanzas varias
cosas crecen exponencialmente
o de caen exponencialmente bueno vamos a
pensar que crece al 10% cada año y eso
es exponencial sí pero es increíble
estas constantes físicas no nos deja de
maravillar cómo es que funciona esto no
hay esto me parece una locura sólo
podemos tener teorías aquí y para tratar
de generalizar
si las constantes físicas dependen en la
unidad que estás utilizando y dependen
en un montón de cosas y en estos casos
este la verdad en todas mis teorías son
bastante vagas pero creo que voy a
pensar un poco más de acuerdo